if we can approximate that a human to a
monkey to a mouse to a fish to a fruit
fly is at least somewhat similar there
may be a a pretty serious discovery
awaiting us that says something along
the lines of if there is a lack of
neurotransmission occurring where there
is supposed to be when it's supposed to
happen for especially when you're doing
some sort of a task that usually gets
you neurotransmission like a reward like
a behavior that usually gets you a
reward like in the case of people with
depression it's like if you get out of
the house and go and exercise or go and
read a book or go and do something meet
with friends do something that is it
drives you closer to your goals if
you're not getting the same
neurochemical flows that you should be
that's a big problem mm-hmm that's it
yeah
if our memory encoding system is having
issues with neurochemical flows then
there may be a much better specifically
targeted way of doing stimulation to
reintroduce those original neuro
chemical flows to continue people in the
direction of when I do something what
I'm supposed to get a neurochemical
release then I actually get it then
straight stimulation is a very
interesting field that has a lot of you
know ultrasound electrical stimulation
magnetic stimulation a lot of
interesting very careful stimulation is
very important very precise stimulation
is very important but healing people was
very important healing people uh-huh
bringing people back to their healthiest
and most cream
native flow states being is very
important